All right. Hello everybody for our zoom call. It is, ooh, the wrong date on here. Sorry about that. It is what is the date? It is the first of May, 2019. Today we're going to be talking about dealing with pain and pain particularly to cancer pain and inflammation that it coincides with that.
So that's what we want to discuss in our talk today. So as we move on here, there is multiple ways to deal with pain. The first thing that the average person of the population does with pain is to take some paid medication.
Now these are hard paid medications here. These are strong paid medication. These are conics, but most people with am a headache or they have a sore shoulder or they have some sort of pain. They're going to grab it over the counter.
Tylenol or a leaf or naparicid or something like that that's going to help decrease the paid and helps them to continue on with life and doing that once in a while is not necessarily a horrible thing.
But that certainly doesn't want to be our first go to the first question that we should all ask when we have paid of any kind is why do I have paid.
So the why I have paid is an important thing to know because you want to deal with the reason why so if I have paid let's say I have breast cancer and I have paid at that cancer site that might not be necessarily a bad thing.
You could have a greater inflammatory response at that cancer site that's helping kill the cancer because an immune response to a site of any kind is going to be an inflammatory response.
That's why we talk about not all inflammation is bad inflammation so we don't necessarily want to just shut down inflammation and shut down paid when that inflammation could be in an immune response that could be helping kill the cancer.
So there's that balance of understanding why the paid is there and and looking at that too doesn't mean that we want to just suffer through paid but it does give us a different understanding that if I have a little bit of pain around a cancer site well I can tolerate that that might be a good thing to just tolerate.
However, paying it let's say I have colored cancer that really bad got paid.
It's not good to just kind of suffer through that as well we don't ever want to get on the wrong side of pain.
Meeting that we that paid is becomes uncontrollable and it's causing us to not be able to continue with our activities of daily living.
But going to a strong narcotic might not be the best thing to do right off the mat.
A matter of fact, I don't think even someone who's pushing narcotics would say that that's the best thing to do right off the mat.
We do want to look at some other alternate ways to deal with that paid once we discover why it's there and it's something that we want to diminish.
Other than jumping onto narcotics, one could say that if we're going to be on a narcotic that could be something that too much of that could lead to our demise in itself.
So we don't want to be careful in how we use our products.
So some natural helps to paid are here as listed.
Curcumin is a natural help to paid. That's a natural anti inflammatory. It's a natural cancer killer.
White will bark is very common thing you think of with dealing with paid more so probably with joint paid than with paid in an organ.
But it can still help corseted is a benefit for pain, Boswellia has a benefit for pain, especially with intestinal inflammation and pain.
Batalins are really good for pain. Batalins are found in beats.
Bromalade commonly found in pineapple is good for pain. Other enzymes are good for pain. Rosemary is good for pain. CBD and THC we've spoken about that at length in other zoom calls. That is very good for pain.
Ginger is good for pain. There's a lot of other things that I didn't list here also.
Here's some in this little thing that I found online that could be good for different types of paid.
But we're talking about paid at a tumor site. We typically think of these types of nutrients to help limit pain.
Some of these can work better for different people than other things too. I've had patients that didn't respond to curcumin at all and responded really well to high dose Boswellia or corseted.
Batalins have had people respond very well to batalins as well. We're going to talk about a product that has specific batalins in it.
And that enzymes not just bromalade, but other enzymes in the digestime plus product that we have.
And the cleansing can be extremely beneficial for pain, especially with reducing inflammation in the liver as well.
Using and what could just do a talk on this with just essential oils as well rosemary as an herb taking orally or as an essential oil can be extremely beneficial.
That's the same thing with ginger as well.
Juicy ginger, whole ginger cutting little slices of an often juiceted can be extremely beneficial for pain. Of course, it can be hard on the tummy a little bit if you use too much of it.
So be careful. But it can be really beneficial to decrease inflammation of the gut and decrease nausea.
And then the THC CBD is probably the strongest natural pain relievers that is out there, especially for visceral pain in the organs.
So using THC, we've had lots of people use a CBD products for pain or using marijuana directly smoking marijuana is one of the better paid relieving things that a person can do, especially with visceral pain.
This is a clear inflamed product that we have that has curcumin, of course, it did most well, it has stiggy, nettle, it has ginger and some rosemary.
So this is a great one to help decrease inflammation locally.
This limitless product is one that's probably we just talked about, this is staff E.J. probably one of our most underused products that's that this company actually purchased the rights.
There was a there was a laboratory that discovered how to to take battalins from from beats without the sugar.
So they actually have a patent on the way to process battalins without sugar. So they process the battalins out of the beats and give you straight battalins.
That's what this product is. And if you have paid that you haven't been able to control with other natural needs, I highly suggest you look at this on our site, because I've known people that have had that were taking like 20 ad vill a day to start taking this limitless product.
This limitless product had completely go off of that completely. So this could this could be really a life changer. There's a lot and lots of testimonials on this product for for pain.
In inflammation that are pretty cool. So look at that product itself to try a bunch of different essential oils.
We could give you a list of different essential oils that are anti inflammatory. You could also Google those essential oils that are anti inflammatory and that could help with paid I put rosemary on here, but literally there's dozens of them.
And certainly try ginger and the CBD product that we have the CBD product. We have two ones that I would say to use if you if pain is an issue, this evolved, interrog this new one that we have that I spoke about in another couple of other videos is so beneficial because it is water soluble, it's organic.
And it's a nano particle. So the absorbability of this is about 80 to 90% of what you take versus any other CBD product owned on the market, the absorbability and what actually gets into your bloodstream is only about 10% of what you take in.
This premium hemp product here, the benefit of this is it's it's one of the very few super high dose CBD products on the market, this one in the upper right hand corner, if you can't see my cursor.
That is that is super high dose. We've had numerous patients use that with much benefit with pain. I've used this with benefits with pain.
This has been a good product comes on as a paste. It's in a syringe. It's hard to see because it's in a box here, but it comes on as a pretty thick paste. Keep it in the refrigerator and you take just
I was taking about a centimeter syringe out under my finger and take it. It doesn't have really much of a taste.
The valve and tarage has some benefits because it also has the immune product in it too. So you don't only get the CBD but you get the yellow benefits for kids are killing as well.
There's some hints to do with pain to try to stay away from these guys if you possibly can do so and reduce these.
If you're on any of the narcotic pain relievers, you do want to try to limit those as much as possible, but you don't want to do so at the expense of letting the pain get out of control.
So I would suggest if you're taking these, you talk to your doctor about, well, at least start on some of these things and then see and talk to your doctor about boy, I feel like my pain that are control I want to decrease the dosage or you can make the choice to do that yourself, but I can't tell you to decrease your dosage or your medications, but at least consider that.
All right, we are going to unmute everybody and open it up for questions. So anybody with any questions?
Dr. Connors, I have a couple of questions.
This is Donna from Arkansas. How are you to really know if that pain is a good pain or a bad pain?
You know, I don't, I don't have a tumor. So a lot of the things that I see on the market target tumors, but mine is more in the blood.
What's for my llama?
But I've been experiencing pain for over a year. I don't take any narcotics at all.
I just deal with it. I've been putting the CBD oil on it.
But, um, so with a bloodboard cancer, it's a little bit different, but most of the pain for multiple myeloma is going to be due to the issue in the bone.
Yeah.
So one of the issues with multiple myeloma is it could cause an osteoclastic meeting a bone breakdown.
That's where you get the pain. So then you look at it a little bit different.
And all these things that we listed here would be beneficial for multiple myeloma because all these things would also target the bone.
You'd also want to think of EGCG green tea extract for that as well.
Yeah, we have you on that because that is that is what is one of the very few products that are known to decrease interleukin six, which is an inflammatory cytokine that is involved.
It's involved with bold breakdown. So make sure that the matter.
In fact, there's some there's some new information on curcumin that that could be involved in that same reaction to help decrease I all six.
And I'm trying to remember if it was ginger was a part of that too. There's another study I'll have to pull that up.
I was talking about some other things that could do that same thing. So all these things would pertain to you as well.
And because it would they would all be beneficial for bold.
So you could equate all these to that.
Yeah, I take white willows for pain instead of aspirin.
Yeah.
I take the curcumin sure clear.
I take those three a day.
But I try.
Three a day is four multiple myeloma.
If you read some of the studies and multiple myeloma, that is one of the cancers that people are having greater success with really high dose curcumin.
So you think I should up it more than three a day.
You could triple back.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Okay.
And you may want to also play with some different sources of the curcumin just for your benefit.
Like like you start start learning some recipes to use turmeric in recipes.
Oh, yeah.
I've been doing that.
And make sure that there are recipes that contain a lot of other fats.
So that they're like good, you know, Indian food recipes that also contain a lot of coconut oil or something like that.
That's what most of those recipes do.
Yeah.
So that you get the benefit of it being absorbed in fat.
That's going to be increase your absorbability of that as well.
Correct.
Okay.
I've been experimenting with how I just started with the Siac.
Yeah.
And wanted to kind of get a feeling for you.
Some people say that if you take it, it's actually absorbing and taking away all the minerals out of your body.
Have you heard that?
No.
I mean, I've heard that, but that is total.
It's just not correct.
Because if you look at what's in Siac are just several really good herbs.
You know, so it is not affecting your minerals in your body.
That's no data to show that at all.
But it is a type of detox.
Is that correct?
I would not say that.
I would say it is sense because it is those same herbs are really good for liver.
They are helping your liver detoxify.
So in that sense, yes.
And I've had non cancer patients take Siac for that purpose.
So it can be good for everybody.
If you're a non cancer patient, I wouldn't say that you should take it all the time.
But do we do, you know, do we do bottle every three months or something as a detox?
That would be a wise thing to do.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
A little bit concerned when they said, oh, that's going to strip all the minerals out of your body.
I'm like, oh, but okay.
Very good.
Well, thank you.
I hope your venture with your cancer is going well.
We pray for you every single day.
Well, thank you.
Thank you.
I have good days and bad days.
I'm actually at home today doing the Zoom call I left early because it's just a little pooped out.
Yeah.
I'm saying that.
Okay.
Well, we're planning on coming up to see you sometime this summer.
She's had a plan to do that.
I, you know, I just, why you wouldn't come up in the winter?
I just didn't understand.
That that was orange out the Chicago and I know we're so.
It'll be great to see.
That's right.
Very good.
Well, let things to you.
Thank you.
All right.
Any other questions today?
Well, I'm encouraged to see everybody is using the Facebook group more and more.
And I hope that you're scrolling down and.
And looking at other people's questions because lots of times that answers your questions.
Somebody already had that question.
And I do hope you're going to our YouTube channel and subscribing to that because we have, I think,
we'll close to 400 videos on there.
If you really want to dirt out a different things.
And those are all available to you as well.
All right.
One question.
Yes.
Dr. Connors.
I'm dealing with prostate metastatic prostate cancer.
John Cozad from Texas.
Yes.
How you doing?
And I've had.
Doing really well.
My prostate, my PSA's come down from 100 to 7.7.
So.
Well, that's really good news.
So that's really good.
Yes, sir.
And then.
I had my lit that liver enzyme tested two months ago.
I think it's the all.
Yep.
The LT.
It was like a thousand sixty three.
And.
So did you have a test it again?
No, I have not.
Okay.
So that's a really that's an inexpensive test for your doctor run.
So have them do your liver enzymes again.
All right.
And see what's going on.
I've had people with super high liver enzymes just because they're detoxing something.
Okay.
And then it goes back down to normal.
And, um, but sustained high enzymes, you know, you're concerned with what's going on in the liver.
Okay.
And if it's high, if it's high again, they should do an ultrasound or a CT or MRI of your liver to see what they see.
It's going on.
Okay.
That would be an appropriate thing to do.
All right.
But it's super encouraging that your PSA is coming down.
And hopefully your, your ALT will be back close to normal range too.
Let me know right away when you get that test.
I would call your doctor.
It's probably might be too late though, but I would call in the morning and just try to get it to get that test done.
Okay.
Because that's part of metabolic panel.
You can ask for a liver enzyme pedal to the same thing.
Okay.
We'll do.
Thank you.
John, if he, uh, we're on some milk.
I know that helped bring mine down.
Yep.
That would be, I don't, I don't have his chart in front of me.
So I don't know what he's taking.
But, um, he's probably doing some, um, we usually give everybody, it's probably doing some, um, liver things.
And, John, I can look at your chart tomorrow to refresh myself to see what you're taking it.
Call your back if we need to tweak something.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh, you sure you bet.
Absolutely.
Also, if he's lost his gallbladder, I don't know if he has a gallbladder or not, John, but.
I have it.
Yes.
Okay. That's good.
Because the ox bile has really helped me.
Uh, since I don't have a gallbladder anymore.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
All right.
Well, we will talk to you guys next week.
Thanks for being on here.
Well, thank you so much.
Oh, you bet.
Bye-bye.